we have another ad brought to you by
libs of tick tock this time twix
sponsoring this
halloween ad
that uh for your viewing pleasure we
will now play
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
i'm your new nanny i don't need a nanny
got an appropriate response when a witch
shows up a witch that's right
i guess that lady's a witch parents seem
to think you do
she broke into the house whoa
she operated she was she was jogging tim
other than black in booth oh exactly
charcoal
why are you all dressed up it's not
halloween yet
can i help you are you a good witch or a
bad witch do you want to find out
there are no good witches
i want to find out
you buckled i'm still wearing my
princess dress do you want to wear why
is this kid getting into the car with a
stranger
that's your baby so also i like how they
it wasn't obvious enough he's wearing a
princess dress yes they both have to say
it out loud
that's what it's about it also wasn't
obvious that he was a boy
you look like a girl why are you wearing
that dressing like this makes me feel
good is that your nanny she looks weird
you look weird your nanny looks weird
you guys are both weird
bass dude right siri i wanna be friends
with that kid whoa
whoa
where is it coming from
what's happening
she just
seriously hurt that child that's just
some child abuse going on what is
happening we should go she read too much
and she knows she committed her crimes
she's like let's get out of here she's
it come back
in the scene of the crime what did she
do to that kid bro you know what what
was that all right the chimpanzees and
the tang weren't so bad right okay let
me i just got it that child needs some
parents yeah
yes i got to clarify for everybody we
have to make this statement
do not
use your magic powers to harm children
physically because they said things that
you found offensive that's right well
think about that ad i mean a lot of
people are like it's grooming children
i'm like it's a kid wearing a dress but
it's more like
she physically harms a child for saying
mean things
harms
i understand no one's really going to
cast a wind spell and blow a kid into
the sky or something but we certainly do
have activists who hurt others for
saying things that they disagree with
that is happening all the time
now apparently that was selling twix
what yeah i didn't know i have no
no no desire to purchase a candy cookie
with caramel in it in any capacity in
fact i i i just want to get a raw steak
not once
right yeah none of that not once was i
appetized yeah also what i find
is that it's a happy halloween
commercial but the kid wasn't apparently
in a costume yeah what's that about i
don't know
was it after halloween no it was it was
the kid the other kid said uh you look
weird
and it's not halloween yet why are you
dressed daylight and everything oh yeah
yeah well i guess it isn't halloween yet
the other thing is like that chick
didn't look weird at all sitting alone
in a house wearing a princess dress
watching tv there's no parents to
strangers and then and then like a
stranger shows up and says i'm the nanny
and the kid's like i don't know about
that and they break into the house and
then so like all right the kid closes
the door yeah so let's look at all kinds
of really bad messages yeah i would
agree let's
to him a nanny is coming over he's
getting a nanny it's just not part of
the story she breaks in anyway right if
the kid doesn't let her in
where are the parents in any of this she
did the same thing to them at the end
yeah she's like i want a child she's
like i want to take this child to my
lair don't don't witches eat kids yes
that's what she's doing here we have a
culture that is intentionally driving a
wedge between children and parents he's
doing that on purpose yep yep
now corporations are on board with that
as well 100 that's part of i mean when
you look even at the uh the biden
child care thing he wants his whole
administration wants children to be out
of the home yeah by 3 p.m
by three three years old sorry not three
pm
they want kids out of the home by three
years old being educated in state
institutions being run by teachers
unions and national school board
association members and they want the
parents somewhere else
doing anything else and not being
connected to the kids or paying
attention to what their children are
doing or being taught this this ad
actually aligns really well with the
loud and county stuff that when they say
the parents have no right to their own
children
yeah exactly
yes they do believe that they believe
that fully 100 to quote michael males
again the most quoted man on this show
that's right the most disturbing thing
about socialists is not that they think
your property is their property it's
that they think your children are their
property yeah and actually i talked to a
woman who um is an american who was
living in norway and she was saying that
you know how
in the u.s people are always like oh in
scandinavian countries they have
everything right on they're really doing
it right she was saying that because
there are so many taxes paid and so much
of that goes to support children and
child care and family leave and all of
that that the citizens in norway feel a
right to tell parents how to raise their
kids yeah
not cool not cool i'd rather have zero
of your money and you get no say in how
i raise my family they're so so that's
why they want to do it that way i mean i
think it's intentional something
interesting in this commercial too is
when the kid he says wearing the dress
makes me feel good
as if like children should just be doing
whatever makes their right feel
yeah yeah i mean there's a reason that
children are not supposed to just do
what makes them feel good we're supposed
to learn how to grow up and be
productive members of society and take
care of ourselves and take care of the
people we love it's like bad obviously
bullying is a bad thing but to kill a
child
well i don't know
the thing about
like she's saying it but we know when
she runs she's like let's get out of
here first of all to hurt a child and
then run away like that's that's not a
good look like buy our candy it is kind
of witchy yeah
yeah
but the thing about bullying too is i
don't know about you guys but a lot of
people have been bullied throughout
cultural pressure
in school
i was very badly bullied in school and
now i
i don't give a flying anything of what
anybody says about me at any point well
it's the advantage of disadvantage
you're strong
everybody who cares exactly and so i
think to a certain extent
uh trying to protect kids from every
conceivable confrontation is bad we
shouldn't do that kids need to figure
out how to navigate these situations oh
one hundred percent i'm not wondering
with you on that i wonder if there are
kids who will see this and then think
that they can attack somebody you know
what i mean
like i understand magic's not real but
the message was clearly that he was
physically harmed and even says will he
be coming back and she's like i don't
know probably she's like yeah probably
imagine if the equivalent was she just
picked the kid up and threw him like
over a fence or something exactly at a
certain point i think i think we're
gonna start seeing kids just feel shame
for being straight and gender conforming
yeah it's it's okay so it's already
starting okay okay
what if a little boy wants to play with
trucks and wear pants
and is into girls
they are targeting boys there was an
insurance company that had to take down
an ad because there was a little boy who
was running through a house being joyful
wearing a dress trashing everything they
took down this ad because it gave people
the impression that they would be
covering this kind of damage to a house
they're like this is not correct this is
not true they are trying to get boys
because like abigail schroeder talks
about girls are exceedingly susceptible
to this boys are not
a boy wearing a skirt in a twix
commercial might convince a little boy
that this is a normal thing to do well
take a look
about that insurance commercial let me
show this thing real quick
so this is from instagram there's
something that i actually saw when i was
browsing reddit
it's called folks health and it says
folks health is rewriting the script for
lgbtq plus healthcare
get hormone replacement therapy
delivered to the comfort of your home no
barrier no stigma
doesn't seem smart well i don't know
about the legalities of this i i know
that prescription medication you have to
get at a pharmacy so i don't know if
they can deliver prescription medicine i
have no problem with that my concern
here is are there going to be safeguards
to make sure that underage you know
exactly individuals children
are not
using this system to self-medicate
without approval from their doctors
i'm not saying they are i'm just saying
like we're seeing active promotion
you get ads for everything and i think
all of it's bad like i remember you
there's commercials for every drug and
they're like call your doctor and see if
this drug is right for you and i'm like
no why i feel fine yeah why am i gonna
sometimes i want to try it i'm like i
will call the doctor this commercial
i think i think it was lunesta i
remember you know very well the
butterfly yeah
and i didn't know what that stuff was
and it was like call your doctor so it's
a sleep aid right the issue is when you
have major pharmaceuticals being like we
want to sell a drug
and whether you're a minor or not
they're telling people to buy their drug
i've never been a fan of that whether
it's for hormone therapies or not
someone could call and be like hey i'm
feeling these symptoms and they could be
like here's some drugs right when people
not everybody has chemically imbalanced
uh depression not everybody has bipolar
disorder some people get depressed
because of literal social problems
that can be solved by going to a
community gathering going jogging
exercising and the problem is when you
tell people that they say things like
you're you're you're undermining my
illness or you're you're downplaying it
there are people who say things like yo
if you're depressed just go for a jog
and it's because jogging has been it
really
but some people do have medical issues
that result in chemical depression now i
i i don't think we're talking about
those people if you could go to a doctor
if you're feeling bad and they diagnose
you with a chemical imbalance or
something then by all means get the
treatment you need but for a lot of
people it is good advice just to go and
and feel better and get some sunshine
and get some sunshine but guess what
pharmaceutical companies got to sell you
know they got to sell i thought it was
interesting that pharmaceutical
companies are allowed to sell on tv but
hard alcohol companies for a long time
were not allowed to
sell their products on tv that's why we
only have beer commercials yeah it is
kind of crazy to advertise
pharmaceuticals on television that
should be something a doctor prescribes
to you if they think it could work for
you like the idea that you fish for
customers
and why don't we have weed
advertisements on tv federal laws i will
point out the the hilarity though of
like me being served an ad for this
because ads are always targeted it
probably has to do a lot with like the
stories we pull up to be completely
honest they're like tim has too much
testosterone we need to get him on some
estrogen well i've been eating a lot of
steak no for real like too much steak no
for real for like the past week i've had
like steak for breakfast and steak for
dinner oh that's awesome because i went
to a farm and i was like i would like a
cow and then they just like give me a
big bag don't have a cow man
i'm sorry tenderloin you know you've got
a good tenderloin you can't buy it in
the grocery store at this point
my like i keep being shy i know this is
off topic but i keep being so shocked at
how much more my same groceries are
costing like six months ago my same two
bags of groceries were forty dollars
another seventy five dollars and i don't
buy meat anymore so it's just going up
even though i've taken all the food out
of my groceries we went to a local farm
and we bought
we did not buy that much meat
the total bill was like 500 bucks
i mean it's good farm fresh meat so it's
going to be more expensive
yeah we got some tenderloins
yo yeah it is
so good yeah we so we have like
porterhouses sirloins strip steaks the
tenderloins were gone instantly because
those are just too good it just melts in
your mouth right
and then we try cooking t-bone and
t-bone's hard to get right porterhouse
is pretty good supporter house has got
some tenderloin on it the sirloins are
great the strip steaks were great but
the t-bones we just couldn't get yeah
really tough yeah tough didn't know that
so we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
slow-cook them
but then we're gonna we're gonna go out
fridays and there's a local farm like
really close
and i'm just going to be like i will
take all of your tenderloin i'm just
going to buy all of it up because that's
that's just what you want it's so good
that's all you're eating well i mean you
know it's kind of crazy because i've
been i've been cutting out all the
processed garbage and i think it was
jack pacob who posted this photo
it was like life america before
processed food and it shows like normal
looking people yeah every like dude all
of the guys walking around have like six
packs they all look fine all the women
are thin yeah and then we introduce like
automatic donut machines right have you
ever seen the automatic pancake machines
no i've used them yeah at hotels you
press the button and then you watch this
like the pancake batter go down and then
there's two heated conveyor belts that
cook it and then just falls out and
you're like there's a fresh pancake kind
of cool wow i don't eat any of that
garbage so i've just been like steak
sounds good you know i make all that
stuff i make fresh i make crepes i make
waffles i make all that stuff at home
sugar is bad well you don't have to put
sugar in it no it is sugar
what is pancakes
high glycemic that's only carbohydrates
put all that stuff in it no no it
literally is it's high glycemic yeah
flour is high glycemic well i'm still
going to make pancakes and that's why i
just eat crepes i've been eating like
just meat and i'm not eating eating no
meat thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you